practiquemos un poco sustituyendo
valores positivos y negativos para las
variables nos piden evaluar x menos
negativa donde x es igual a menos 2 y ya
es igual a 5 así que en todos los
lugares donde veamos una x la podemos
sustituir con un -2 y en todos los
lugares donde veamos una ye la
reemplazamos con un 5 esta es una ley y
esta es una equis hagamos eso en lugar
de esa x escribiremos menos 2 tenemos
menos 2 menos y luego abrimos un
paréntesis menos que es igual a que es
igual a 5 y qué valor nos dará esto
bueno esto es lo mismo que menos 2 ahora
restando un -5 todo esto de aquí
restaron menos 5 es lo mismo que sumaron
esto será menos 2 + 5
que será igual a 3 esto será igual a 3
y hay varias maneras en las que podemos
pensar en esto mi cerebro piensa
está bien empezaré en menos dos si sumo
dos llegó a cero y luego tendría que
sumar tres así que eso me lleva a tres
podrías ver esto incluso como mi cerebro
dice menos 2
veamos tengo que sumar tengo que sumar 2
para regresar a cero y luego tengo que
sumar otro 3 si quisiera sumar un total
de 5
esto será 0 + 3 nos da 3 y otra manera
de pensar en eso es menos 2 5 es lo
mismo que 5 menos 25 menos dos que por
supuesto es igual a 3 o puedes dibujarlo
en la recta numérica dirías si piensas
en menos 2 y avanza 5 a la derecha
llegarás a más 3
hagamos otro de estos este es un poco
más un poco más complejo de ambos nos
dicen que evaluemos 3 menos menos 6 más
menos h más menos 4 donde h es igual a
menos 7 hay dos maneras en las que
podrías hacerlo podría solo tomar el
menos 7 y sustituir la h con ese menos 7
o podrías de hecho intentar simplificar
esta expresión primero
hacer la sustitución de hecho hagamos
eso mi cerebro quiere hacer eso
esta expresión tengo el 3 pero en lugar
de restar un -6 eso será lo mismo que
sumar 6 36
y sumar una h negativa es lo mismo que
sólo restar una h
así que 36 menos h y luego sumando un -4
sumando un -4 es lo mismo que restar 4
es lo mismo que restar 4 y ahora por
supuesto podríamos hacer esto en
cualquier ya sabes resta adicional
tenemos podríamos cambiar el orden que
lo haremos hagamos eso para simplificar
todo esto primero que nada tengo que ver
cuánto es 3 + 6 36 es igual a 9 y luego
tengo este menos 4 aquí puedo decir 9
4 de hecho seré cuidadosa de no saltarme
ningún paso 3 más 63 más 6 en un color
que puedas ver tres más 6
99 - h
4 - 4
ahora podría cambiar el orden en el que
hago esta resta adicional así que este
será equivalente a 9 menos 49 - 4 - h -
h sólo hice eso para poder simplificar y
descubrir cuánto es nueve menos cuatro
es por supuesto 9 menos 4 es 5
es mejor simplificar a 5 - h antes de
hacer mi sustitución y ahora puedo
sustituir h con menos 7 así que esto va
a ser igual a esto será igual a cuando
hago la sustitución escribiré aquí
arriba será 5 menos escribiré el menos
en color magenta menos y luego donde vea
a la h
la reemplazar con menos 75 menos 7
tienes que ser muy cuidadoso porque
podrías pensar
tengo un negativo aquí podría sólo
reemplazar a la h con un 7 pero la h es
menos 7 está restando h restar al menos
7 esto es 5 - menos 7 que es lo mismo
que que es lo mismo que 57 57 lo que
todos sabemos es igual a 12 y acabamos
hagamos unos cuantos más de estos
no puedes obtener demasiada práctica
aquí estas son algunas habilidades
matemáticas básicas para el resto de tu
vida matemática ahora considerando la
siguiente recta numérica tenemos una
recta numérica aquí y veamos no marcaron
todos los números aquí este es menos 4
está en este punto este es 2 parece que
estamos contando cada 2 aquí este es
menos 2
este es cero si menos 4 se incrementasen
dos menos 4 - 2 024 esto sería un 6 esto
sería un -6 e intencionalmente deje sus
números afuera para que tuviéramos que
descifrar los mira entre menos 4 y 2
para ir de menos 4 a 2 deberás de sumar
6 y sólo tenemos 123 marcas por lo que
cada marca deberá de estar incrementando
el 2 de cualquier manera ahora sabemos
el valor de todos los puntos en la recta
numérica por lo que evaluamos
sabemos que es igual a menos 2 y sabemos
que f es igual a 4 esto será lo mismo
es igual a menos 2 - 4 - 4 positivo
bueno 2 negativo -4 tenemos una recta
numérica frente a nosotros esto será
menos 6 si empezaste en menos 2 y restas
de 2 llegas a menos 4 y restas otro 2
llegarás a menos 6 así que terminamos
hagamos uno más de estos evaluemos de
más menos uno nuevamente tv están en
esta recta numérica y parece que cada
una de estas marcas incrementa en tres
cuando vamos hacia arriba cero
y si bajamos 0 - 3 - 6 entonces está
claro que uno es igual a 3 y es igual a
3 y también está claro que te es igual a
menos 6 t es igual a menos 6 así que te
más menos 1 será será menos 6
más menos seis más menos
o estrés u estrés debes de ser muy
cuidadoso podrías decir oh
es positiva por lo que sólo pondré un
número positivo pero recuerda es un
negativa donde veas la 1 reemplazarla
con un 3-3 negativo esto será menos 6 +
3 negativo el cual podemos escribir
nuevamente como 6 negativo
- 3
todo esto puede escribirse como menos 6
menos 36 negativo menos 3 si estás en 6
negativo y te mueves 3 a la izquierda
tienes tres unidades más negativas
acabarás en 9 negativo
terminados